♪ ♪ ♪
- La famille Simard
est à l'image des bleuets
qu'elle cultive : rée.
Dans cette bleuetière du rang
Saint-Eusèbe, à Saint-Félicien,
quatre générations sont
à l'oeuvre dans les champs
l'été. Le doyen du groupe,
c'est Raphaël Simard.
Rien ne l'arrête,
pas même ses 97 ans.
RAPHAËL SIMARD, cueilleur
- Ça passe le temps,
puis j'aime ça, ramasser.
C'est rien que pour ça.C'est pas
pour l'argent!
J'avais hâte de m'asseoir!
On dirait que je vieillis!
Je m'attendais pas
à en ramasser cette année,
parce que j'étais pas solide
trop, trop, puis j'avais
de la misère à...
J'avais  marchette,
puis une canne.
Puis, à un moment donné...
Je me sers plus de ça,
puis ça va bien pareil.
- C'est très jeune qu'il a
commencé à ramasser les bleuets
en forêt et sur les terres
de son grand-père au peigne.
Quatre générations ont possédé
la Bleuetière Simard et fils.
Depuis 1990, c'est son garçon
qui veille sur cet héritage.
YOLAND SIMARD, propriétaire,
Bleuetière Simard et fils
- Quand j'étais jeune, lui,
il allait cueillir en forêt,
puis moi, je restais à la ferme
avec mon grand-père pour venir
cueillir ici, mais dans
ce temps-là, je me promenais
avec une chenille un après-midi
de temps, puis j'en prenais
deux là, deux là.(rire)
Il y en avait pas, de bleuets!
♪ C'est bon pour le moral ♪
- Aujourd'hui, la bleuetière
est productive, mais il faut
toujours un coeur solide
pour gérer les soubresauts
de Dame Nature. Raphaël Simard
a sept filles, un garçon
et plusieurs petits-enfants
et arrière-petits-enfants.
Les moments en famille ont donc
de quoi adoucir les jours
difficiles et cet attachement
mutuel se traduit jusque
dans les noms donnés
aux chemins de la bleuetière.
- Quand tu te lèves le matin,
si t'as pas de projet,
à quoi tu penses? Bien lui,
il en a un projet, c'est
les bleuets, ses e
qui sont autour, puis...
il est heureux de même.
CLAUDINE SIMARD, 3e génération
- Pour moi, c'est familial,
parce que c'est un moment
où je peux travailler
avec mon père, puis de voir
mon grand-père aussi ramasser,
puis être heureux parce qu
il est heureux!
C'est sa période de l'année
où il est le plus heureux.
Puis ça, c'est plaisant
de le voir comme ça.
HUGO RAYMOND, arrière-petit-fils
de Raphaël Simard
ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas vu mes grand-maman,
grand-papa, bien, c'est ça,
c'est... je suis content.
- Les proches de Raphaël Simard
savent bien qu'il ne sera pas
éternel. Ils continuent
d'emmagasiner les souvenirs
sur ces terres qui seront cédées
à la prochaine génération.
Le doyen des lieux, lui,
compte cueillir tant
qu'il le pourra.
- Il y a juste le mauvais temps
qui m'arrête, quand il pleut.
- Il est pas capable d'arrêter!
Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire?
Il aime ça!
- Ici Mélissa Paradis,
Radio-Canada, Saint-Félici